When you desire one thing over another
or you want to become one type of person,
but not the other, you may think
that’s your personal preference.
One psychological explanation of human behavior
argues that we often have no idea what we want,
and hence just imitate others
— welcome to mimetic theory.
Mimetic Theory is the idea that there are
really only two sides to human desire.
Physical Desires are our cravings for
utility — the intrinsic value of objects.
Metaphysical Desires are our longing for
identity — what objects can say about us.
If you are hungry, you may want to eat anything
to satisfy a physical need. Or you might wish to
eat out — in which case you may pick a place that
reinforces your self-conception, your identity,
and the person you wish to become. In other words,
you want to please your metaphysical desire.
Rene Girard, the French philosopher who
established the theory, argued that most of our
desires are metaphysical and called them mimetic
because we mimic them from the people around us.
We imitate others, because we
long for their recognition,
hoping that we will eventually become a heightened
being that will be remembered — ideally forever.
However since this ideal is so abstract and
so hard to achieve, we take shortcuts and
make associations with objects and models whom
we think have already achieved this status.
And so, our deepest desires and moral
principles are fundamentally anchored
by models and the objects, values,
and culture associated with them.
In school, we want to wear what the cool
kids are wearing, and by the same logic,
we never ever want to look
like the social outcasts.
This common longing for
and against certain models,
raises a fundamental question: Do
we, in fact, have any autonomy?
If we simply want what others want,
our decisions are not truly ours,
and we are far from being independent
in our behavior. "Individualism is a
formidable lie" Girard wrote.
And this leads to a problem!
The relationship between a subject
and an object unfolds through a model,
also called a mediator — who desires the
same things. Eventually, this can lead
to rivalry between subjects and mediators —
especially if they start imitating each other.
And as both don’t like the thought
that they cannot have what they want,
they look for a victim who
they can make responsible.
As a result they unify their imitative desires
around the destruction of an agreed-upon
scapegoat — to the point where that person is
singled out, expelled, or killed. After the social
order is restored, and people are happy to have
solved their problems - the cycle begins again.
What do you think? Was Girard right, and
are we all trapped in societies that tell
us who we should want to become? Or do
we have our own independent desires that
go beyond our need for food and shelter?
Share your thoughts in the comments below!
If you found this helpful, check
out our other videos and subscribe.
If you want to support our work,
join us on patreon.com/sprouts.
For more information and additional
contents, visit sproutsschools.com